STEVE GROVE: Good morning
and good afternoon.
My name Steve Grove.
I look after a team here at
Google called the News Lab.
We're actually a new team.
About a year old.
We're focused on innovation
in the media landscape.
But before that,
I actually worked
at YouTube, which is where I
first came across David Evan
Harris and the
Global Lives project,
which you're all here today to
learn a little bit more about.
It's really, really a unique
project in the media landscape
today.
We're very pleased to have
David and Naomi joining us here
in Mountain View for this talk.
How many of you have
seen the exhibit
in the lobby of building 43
before coming to this talk?
Show of hands.
Anybody?
Just a few.
OK.
Great.
So this will be
the perfect tee up
for you to go actually
observe the exhibit yourself.
It's right inside the
front lobby of Google.
And it's really a
phenomenal exhibit.
It has over 500 hours of
footage from the daily life
of 20 people in seven
different countries.
And it's really neat.
It's sort of an eight
screen immersive experience
where you get to hear both
the audio and the visual
from lives of these people that
David and Naomi and others have
documented around the world.
And they'll be up here to tell
you about it in just a bit.
Google is just one place this
exhibit has found itself.
It has also been at the
Smithsonian, the United Nations
University.
I think it originally debuted
at the Yerba Buena Art Center
up in San Francisco.
So as I mentioned, I
first met David back
when I was at YouTube
in about 2007.
This was a long time ago
in internet video years.
This was back when Lonely
Girl 13 was a huge phenomenon.
When one of the original viral
videos on the web was a video
called Lazy Sunday from
Saturday Night Live.
If anyone remembers that.
In terms of my own
experience at YouTube,
it was around the same time
that YouTube just started
to be used for politics.
So if you remember George
Allen being caught on a camera
calling his campaign opponent's
videographer a macaca,
that moment being captured,
uploaded to YouTube.
It went viral.
He then lost a very
close race in many ways
because of that clip.
And sort of YouTube
politics had been born.
So YouTube has been used in a
lot of ways since that point.
But David was one of these
really early guys who
I think really recognized
the potential of online video
to really transform how we
understand the world around us.
And I think most importantly,
how we understand the lives
of others who don't
live right next door,
or in the same state, or
even in the same country.
I think when he set aside to
do the Global Lives Project--
and he'll you a little bit
more about it when it comes up.
He didn't want to just go out
there and say, hey, check out
these documentary
films of people
who live around the world and
have different experiences
to you.
He wanted to do it in
a really unique way.
What you see in these film is
a really raw, unvarnished look
at what it's like to
live somewhere else.
He takes the idea
of day in the life,
and he takes it very literally.
It is an actual day in the
life of these individuals
that he goes out and
films 24 hours straight.
Camera runs for
the whole 24 hours.
They get a full
picture of what it's
like to be in that
person's shoes.
And it helps you
answer questions--
to use some of
David's examples--
like what does a
Brazilian rapper do
first thing in the morning?
Or how long does it take
a Palestinian refugee
to walk to dance class?
Or what's it like to get
around the Tokyo subway
when you have to
use a wheelchair?
These are some really
ordinary moments
from which David extracts really
extraordinary stories that
give us a real sense of what
life is like around the world
today.
The program really got
kicking about five years ago,
thanks to several
grants from the National
Endowment for the Arts.
Three years ago,
David took the program
and made it not just about
the videos themselves,
but a curriculum.
For those of you who saw
these booklets on the table
when you came in, this is a
fully immersive curriculum
for schools to use.
Over 1,000 teachers have
this in their classrooms,
and can use it showing
videos from these films,
but also a lot of great
questions and answers.
And a deep curriculum
that David developed
with a group at
Stanford to bring
this work to the classroom.
And when I think
about this project,
it's one of these
things where it's
sort of like private
sector/public diplomacy.
If you talk to somebody
at the State Department,
or any foreign
government about what
it means to understand
cultures around the world, one
of the first things
they always talk about
is like well, if you could
do an educational exchange,
or if you could meet
someone from someplace else,
they no longer seem
like the other.
But they seem like, you know--
you see a notion of sameness,
right?
And that gives you
a new perspective,
I think, empathetic perspective
about the world around you
that's so important.
It's why we're so excited
to have David and Naomi here
with us today.
He is joined as
well by Naomi Ture.
She filmed the Vietnam
portion of this exhibit.
She'll tell you all
about that in a moment.
She's an accomplished filmmaker.
She recently just finished the
project of "Batkid Begins."
How many of you sort of followed
the whole phenomenon of Batkid
in San Francisco?
So Naomi just finished
a film with Time Warner
on that extraordinary story.
She's also been a board
member for Global Lives
for several years.
I'm going to bring up David now
to give us a quick overview.
David's a sociologist.
He's an artist.
He's a curator.
He founded this program, like
I said, way ahead of its time,
before online video
was really a thing.
Back in 2004.
In addition to running this
extraordinary organization,
he's also a Fellow at the
Institute for the Future,
which means he
knows what's coming.
So maybe we can get
to that in the Q&A.
He also was on the staff
at UC Berkeley's Haas
School of Business.
He started out
earlier in his career
at the White House
on the Council
on Environmental Quality,
and spent a lot of time
in Sao Paulo, where he
got his sociology degree.
So without further ado, I'd like
to bring up David Evan Harris.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: Thank you.
Thanks so much, Steve.
It's really an honor to be here.
So I should just
mention, Global Lives
was founded just a few months
before YouTube, actually.
And at the time when we did
our first 24-hour shoot,
we couldn't even
afford a hard drive
that we could put 24
hours of video onto.
It was actually
quite costly. $1,000.
But I followed Moore's law.
And figured that by the time
I finished all of these videos
around the world, I
would be able to afford
the adequate hard
drives to do this.
So let's see.
So one of the big questions
that Global Lives is asking--
and Global Lives really
is not about giving you
specific answers.
It's about asking you questions.
One of these questions is
what are the boundaries
of your moral universe?
And this is a
pretty big question.
And one way I like to think
about what this might mean
is to ask people a question.
So I'm curious in the audience
here if anyone knows or would
like to volunteer a number
about how many people
died in Iraq as a result
of the Iraq war since 2002.
If anyone has an idea
about the numbers there,
the magnitude of
deaths that took place.
AUDIENCE: 300,000.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: 300,000.
600,000.
Anyone else?
No Googling allowed.
1 million?
Couple million.
Yeah.
So this is really interesting.
And so this room is
actually representative
of the broader lack of
agreement on this issue.
There are estimates
that range from 150,000
to a million people.
Just one of the studies
reached a conclusion
that around half
a million people
died as a result of this war.
Now to me, this is
really difficult,
because we do have
exact numbers.
And we do get exact
numbers whenever
members of the American
military or US citizens
are killed in these conflicts.
But we have a margin of error
in the hundreds of thousands
of human lives in our
reporting on this issue.
And to me, what that
says is that there's
a really deep problem
in our society today,
which is that we don't
value human lives equally.
And if someone is of
a different religion,
of a different nationality,
and maybe of a different class,
and living in a different
part of the world,
we don't have the mechanisms to
really think about their life
in the same way,
in the way that we
think about the
lives of other people
that are much closer to us.
So to me, that's a
really important part
of the context of why I started
thinking about Global Lives.
So I'm going to show
a short video that
gives you an introduction
to Global Lives.
And then I'll tell you more.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The world is an
incredibly diverse place.
But it takes experiencing that
diversity on a personal level
to really appreciate
and understand it.
-The Global Lives project
is a video library
of life experience
where we record
24 hours in the daily life of
people from all walks of life,
from all over the world.
-What I think is
very interesting
is the way in which
we present it.
Unraveling in real time,
waking up, eating breakfast,
conversing with your neighbors.
-It's those details that really
make you connect with someone.
All over the world,
no matter where
we are, how we live, we
all laugh, we all cry,
we all care about our families.
-Global Lives
cultivates empathy.
And empathy is at the foundation
of any thriving culture.
-It all began with recording the
life of James Bullock, a cable
car driver here in San
Francisco back in 2004.
Since then, we've done video
shoots in other countries
around the world, including
Brazil, Malawi, Japan, China,
India, Indonesia, Serbia,
Lebanon, and Kazakhstan.
-When selecting
our participants,
we work with
demographics experts
to represent the world's
diversity by age, religion,
income, gender, and occupation.
-It's really transformative to
travel and see other cultures.
But not everyone
has the privilege
to just backpack
around the world
and get to know people
from different places.
Global Lives tries to
bring that to people where
they are, through the internet,
through video installations,
and allow people to have
that experience of seeing
what everyday life is like in
different places in the world.
-In a classroom
environment, it's
very important for the
future leaders of this world
to be able to appreciate
cultures, and be
able to understand that
at the root of it all,
we are all human beings with
the same aspirations and dreams.
-The Global Lives collective is
made up volunteer filmmakers,
photographers, designers,
architects, and everyday people
from all over the world who
are dedicated to sharing
culture and crossing
cultural boundaries.
-There's so many ways and
opportunities to get involved
with the Global Lives Project.
Even just coming to our
website and helping tag videos,
there's plenty of opportunities
to use our resources
and engage in that,
and contribute to that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: So
another big question
that we're asking
through Global Lives
is what could global
empathy look like?
What would it really mean
to be able to empathize
with a person who lives on
the other side of the world?
And a model that we
use, and something
that we've been saying
for about 10 years now,
is step out of your world.
This is really the
request that Global Lives
makes of you as a
viewer and a visitor
to our exhibits to really use
these videos as an opportunity
to step out of your
everyday experience
and imagine yourself into
the life of another person
that you otherwise
couldn't have known.
So this is a timeline of
what we've been up to.
Steve actually covered some
of this in the introduction.
But we have produced 20
videos of the daily life
of individuals in 17 different
countries around the world.
And we've been exhibiting
that in all sorts of venues
ranging from museums
to galleries to schools
all over the world.
So the first shoot that we did
was in 2004, as I mentioned.
And it's been climbing since.
And when you open up the
brochure that I gave everyone,
you'll see that the
shoots are divided
into two sets of series.
And one is the first
10 videos, which we
produced between 2004 and 2009.
And those have a
little 10 next to them.
And the others that have a
cable car icon next to them
are from our Lives
in Transit series.
And the Lives in Transit series
is about transportation workers
all over the world.
And again, all of these videos
are featured in the exhibit.
And I'll be really happy
to take you over there
after this for a tour.
So since this is potentially
a technical crowd,
I wanted to get to some of
the math and the numbers
behind Global Lives.
So this is actually
a spreadsheet
that we used to
figure out who we
wanted to videotape in
different parts of the world.
But we actually did some
work with at the time
a Google employee
who volunteered
to do an animation
for us to explain
how we pick different
people in different places.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The Global Lives
Project set out
to document 24 hours
in the daily life
of 10 people who
roughly represent
the diversity of humanity.
-From the most intimate to
the most mundane moments,
our crews patiently
watched, turning themselves
over to the pace and rhythms
of lives not their own.
-Geography.
61% percent of the world's
population lives in Asia.
So we selected six Asians,
and one person each
from the other four major world
regions-- North America, South
America, Africa, and Europe.
-We also learned that more than
half the world lives in cities.
So we chose five urban
and five rural people.
-Income.
We conducted detailed
economic research
to select 10 people whose
earnings roughly represent
global income distribution.
-Gender.
Half men.
Half women.
-Religion.
The actual religious
distribution of the planet.
-Age.
The actual age
distribution of the planet.
Six of the 10 people
are under 30 years old.
[END PLAYBACK]
DAVID EVAN HARRIS:
So those animations
came out of this
spreadsheet, again.
So what we tried to do is
we developed this concept
of a representativity score.
And this is actually
something that
came from an idea in a
conversation I had with Loren
Carpenter, who's one of
the founders of Pixar,
and invented the software
called RenderMan.
And I told him, Loren, we're
about to finish our 10th shoot.
But we want to keep doing
more of these shoots
all over the world.
And we want to
stick to this idea.
And he said, oh, David.
It's a simple problem.
All you need to do is create a
seven dimensional million cell
by million cell matrix.
And then in that
matrix, you'll be
able to maximize the
distance between all
the different points in each
of the different dimensions.
And just write an algorithm.
And then it will all work out.
And it will guide how you
keep adding to the collection.
And so we're in the process
of implementing Loren's idea
through first a set
of spreadsheets,
and eventually we hope
an online tool that
will allow people to come
to our website and say,
I'd like to produce a
new Global Lives shoot.
How can I propose a person who
adds the most representativity
to the Global Lives collection?
So that's not the
only way that I've
been involved with really
technical communities
in the Global Lives work.
As I was developing this
group-- and now so we
call the group of people who've
contributed to Global Lives
the Global Lives Collective.
And as I was experiencing
the growth of this collective
beyond the size of most arts
collective that you hear about
in the world, I started to look
to other domains for examples.
And one of those was
open source software.
Have any of you
contributed to Debian,
or been involved with the Debian
Linux distribution community?
Anyone know what Debian is?
OK.
We have some nods.
So Debian is a really
interesting open source
community that doesn't have a
strong hierarchical leadership
structure, and at the same time,
continues to produce a really
important Linux distribution.
And so I looked at Debian.
I looked at Creative
Commons, which
is an organization that
produces licenses for art
and creative content
that are very much
inspired by and analogous to
open source software licenses.
And in many ways,
Global Lives is
taking that ethos of open source
that is behind open source
software, behind
Wikipedia, and taking that
to the world of film through
licenses like Creative Commons.
So we do our
exhibits in all sorts
of different shapes and sizes.
These are just a few examples.
We've done circular exhibits.
We've done square exhibits.
And we've done exhibits
with projectors, with TVs.
This is the exhibit
that's here at Google.
And again, I'd be really
happy to invite all of you
on a tour of that exhibit
as soon as the talk is over.
And it's not far from here.
Now that same exhibit has spent
time at schools like this one.
This is Envision
Academy, a public school
in downtown Oakland.
And we've taken the exhibit
to dozens of schools.
Sometimes schools
use our equipment.
And sometimes schools put
together their own exhibits
using their own equipment.
There was a school in
India two years ago
that actually had 10
projectors, and brought them
all into their gymnasium,
projected on the walls,
and had a 24-hour marathon
video watching session
where it was a
boarding school where
the students brought
sleeping bags
and watched for
the full 24 hours.
So we really encourage people
to build their own exhibits.
So a lot of the filmmakers
that have been involved
with Global Lives have been able
to benefit from a production
guide that we produced at
the beginning of our Lives
in Transit series.
We really wanted to standardize
this methodology for producing
films.
So the guide goes
through every aspect
of how to produce a 24-hour
shoot with one person.
From pre-production,
identifying the person,
getting to know the community,
building a strong relationship,
to the day of production, to
microphones, to batteries,
et cetera.
And then the whole
post-production process,
guidelines for file
naming, metadata.
This stuff is really
important to us.
This is an example of
the equipment checklist
that you would use to
put together everything
you need to do a shoot.
And it's pretty extensive,
because we really
want the shoots to succeed.
Some of the filmmakers
have told me afterwards
that one of the aspects of doing
a Global Lives shoot that they
like is the technical
challenge of actually producing
24 continuous hours
of usable video.
I have one filmmaker who's
also a marathon runner.
And he said it's a very
similar experience, actually.
And there's a lot of
teamwork in there too.
So our website, we actually--
going back to the theme
we mentioned earlier-- Global
Lives predated web video
as we know it, basically.
When we were starting
this project,
people were still emailing
WMV files to each other.
And it was a different time.
I originally intended this
work as a video installation.
But as the web evolved, first
from being our primary medium
for communication
between filmmakers
around the world into a place
to share about the work we were
doing, it eventually
evolved into being
one of the primary
ways-- actually I
should say the biggest way that
people experience Global Lives
videos is through our website.
So on the website you can
explore the collection
through a grid, or
also through a map that
shows you the relationships
and the connections
between different people.
And we're always looking for
ways to improve the website.
So if any of you are
excited about using
your technical skills for
this, please, please let me
know afterwards.
I would love to really
have your input.
So I wanted to get into a
couple of the actual people.
So this is Seunghwan.
And he's part of our
Lives in Transit series.
He actually lives in the
neighborhood of Gangnam,
that probably all of
you have heard of, known
for Gangnam style, the song,
in Seoul, in South Korea.
And he works for a
company called Any Man.
He rides a motorcycle around
Seoul and delivers things.
He assembles a chandelier.
He does all kinds of
different odd jobs
over the course of his day.
This is Ivan.
He is a horse cart driver
in Cali, in Colombia.
And you can see the crew
riding the horse cart.
It's hard to get a stable image
from the back of a horse cart.
But you can see they're
using a Steadicam rig there
that's shoulder mounted.
And then this is Laura.
She's a traveling circus
performer in Spain.
And the form of transit
that she's involved in
is the transit of
an entire circus.
This is definitely
a popular one.
And this is Ruixian.
And she is a long distance
train worker in China.
And so she actually spends
most of the 24 hours
actually on a moving
train during the shoot.
And then this is Mingmar.
And he is a caterpillar
fungus harvester in Nepal.
And the form of transit
that he's involved in
is actually his feet.
He hikes for about a week
and a half in each direction
to this remote area
of the Himalayas
where he collects this extremely
valuable fungus that grows
on the backs of caterpillar.
So again, I gave you
all the brochure.
And you can read more about
each of them, and even more
on our website.
I have exciting news.
Global Lives has been accepted
into the New York Film Festival
for 2016.
So Lives in Transit.
We're wrapping up
post-production on that.
What you're seeing is
a work-in-progress view
of the Lives in Transit series.
So Lives in Transit
will premiere globally
at Lincoln Center in
September of next year.
And there are a lot of people
in the Google New York office
who are actually excited
about being involved in that,
perhaps having this exhibit
go to Google in New York
before that.
So I want to actually show a
clip from our shoot in Vietnam
before I bring up Naomi,
one of our filmmakers.
But before I do
that, I owe a couple
of really big thank yous to
the GO Arts program, and Janice
[INAUDIBLE], who was the curator
who brought the Global Lives
exhibit to Building 43.
Esther Wojcicki, who's on our
advisory council for Global
Lives, and was a big part
of bringing the exhibit here
as well.
Of course, Steve and his
Steve' wife, Mary Grove,
have been talking about
doing this exhibit with me
for about four years.
It's been a long road.
We benefit a lot as well from
the Google Reach Local program,
which is soon to be
Google Local Leadership.
We met a team of three
Googler volunteers
a couple weeks ago that actually
helped build that exhibit,
and did lot of work
on audio editing
and getting footage
onto our website.
And then also a
really big thanks
to Rosa Wu, who is
standing in the back there.
So Rosa is a Googler, and a
member of the Global Lives
board of directors.
And she is also equipped with
a donation-accepting computer
if you want to make a
contribution this holiday
season to Global Lives.
And it will be doubled
by your employer, Google.
So with that, let me show you
some footage from Vietnam.
And then we'll talk a
little bit more about it.
[SPEAKING VIETNAMESE]
STEVE GROVE: Great.
Thank you, David.
Naomi, why don't you
come up and join us.
Round of applause for the film.
[APPLAUSE]
So David, let's start with you.
Going back to 2004, what
gave you the inspiration
to start this whole thing?
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: So
actually it was in 2002
that I had the idea.
I was in college.
And I was traveling
as part of a study
abroad program where I
had this amazing luck
to be able to live in
five different countries
over the course of the year.
And I went to Tanzania, India,
the Philippines, Mexico,
and the UK.
I lived in a bamboo
house in the Philippines.
I lived in a former squatter
settlement in Mexico City.
I lived in a mansion with
five servants in New Delhi.
And that experience is
something I really want
to share with other people.
And I then went on to get a
graduate degree in sociology.
But I was feeling like in my
writing, my academic writing,
it wasn't really getting
across just what you
can gain from really
spending time one-on-one
or in someone's home
with another person.
So I wanted to share that.
That's really where
the idea came from.
It was a very long process.
But that's how we
arrived at that.
But still every week we get
inquiries through our website
from filmmakers that
want to continue
adding to the collection.
And we're looking for ways to
find the resources to continue
producing more and more video.
STEVE GROVE: Naomi, we just
saw a clip from your experience
in Vietnam.
How long ago was that?
NAOMI TURE: That was like, 2003.
STEVE GROVE: 2003.
OK.
So you're a filmmaker.
Your traditional process
of filmmaking, I'm sure,
is documentary style.
You shoot.
You stop.
You take a drink of water.
You keep going.
This is very different.
You filmed for 24
hours straight.
Tell us what that's like.
NAOMI TURE: Yeah.
So I think we
mentioned this before.
But it's really kind of the
ultimate filmmaking challenge.
It's like endurance filmmaking.
So obviously preparation is
months and months in advance,
as in any documentary.
But this is a
logistical challenge.
STEVE GROVE: And
is it you holding
the camera the entire time?
Like you personally are holding
one camera for 24 hours?
NAOMI TURE: So no.
So we definitely had a team.
So I had a team of seven people.
Four of us were actually
holding the camera.
The cinematographers.
And the rest are just support.
And so logistically,
the way we do it
is actually Alfred
Hitchcock style.
So we want the
experience for the viewer
to feel as though it's a
constant-- we're filming
from when they go to sleep,
their entire sleep, turning
around in sleep.
They wake up.
They brush their teeth.
They wash their face.
They're exhausted.
And then they finally get
their caffeine or whatever they
need for the morning and go.
So because we're filming
every single possible minute,
and no camera in the world
can film for 24 hours.
There's no card.
Well, actually there
are ways to do that.
But what we needed was, you
need at least two cameras
and at least two
camera operators.
So you're constantly signaling
to the other camera operator
and switching cameras.
And in order to kind of
transition to the next thing,
you'll move the camera
to maybe a black space
while the next person
begins filming.
STEVE GROVE: What
do you do about
like showers and bathrooms?
I mean, these people are
living an actual life.
So doing things they probably
don't want on camera,
obviously.
NAOMI TURE: Yeah.
We give very little privacy.
But when they do
go to the bathroom,
then we do allow them to
go behind the closed doors.
STEVE GROVE: We have
this too, if you wanna.
NAOMI TURE: On the
boat in Vietnam though,
the bathroom is open to the sky.
So all of us, crew, onscreen
participant, all of us
had to just go in a box
that then would flush right
into the river, which you then
later on pulled up the river
water to wash the dishes.
STEVE GROVE: Fascinating.
So you're given an assignment.
Tell me how it works.
You're given an assignment from
David and team, or whoever,
to go to Vietnam.
How early in advance--
are you like contacting
a potential subject of your
film months in advance?
Or how does this work in terms
of approaching the people
you're gonna profile?
NAOMI TURE: Yeah.
So I was actually behind
the scenes for six years
before I actually
became a filmmaker.
So I was on the board, on
the production committee,
and looking at
all the proposals.
So yeah, it's month in advance.
Every proposals
and actual specific
person that you've researched,
that the team in that area.
So my team in Ho Chi Minh City
drove down to rural Vietnam,
right below [INAUDIBLE]
in My Khanh village,
found someone who's
willing to participate.
And then we assemble.
STEVE GROVE: I'm interested
in the willing to participate
moment.
This woman, Huyen, from
the film that you profiled.
What's the pitch look like?
And what kind of
reactions did you get?
NAOMI TURE: So actually I
was able to see her reaction,
because we lost our
participant a day
before we were about to film.
So we had motorbiked across the
whole city of Ho Chi Minh City,
gathered all of our equipment,
had the production van.
We were ready to go
down, called [INAUDIBLE]
who was our original
participant.
And he said, oh, I'm
really, really sick.
And I can't participate.
And I've been sent home.
So I'm no longer on
the boat anymore.
And so we drove
down to [INAUDIBLE],
which is the largest city
in the Mekong River delta
region in Vietnam to
find another participant.
And so we split up into
teams of people, each one
with a Vietnamese local.
And we went from boat
to boat asking, hey,
would you be willing to be
filmed for 24 hours tomorrow
morning starting at 5:00 AM?
And so of course, that's
an interesting question.
And I think the response
was always positive
because people are
interested in revealing
something of themselves.
You know.
And I think we all want
to share in this idea
of like kind of
global connectedness
and global empathy.
And so we had a lot
of positive responses.
The issue was that we
had to find someone
of a certain age demographic, of
a certain religion, et cetera.
STEVE GROVE: David,
do you find this
to be true in most of the
situations in which you're
filming these 24-hour shoot,
that people are surprisingly
willing to do it?
DAVID EVAN HARRIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
That's a question that comes up.
And another piece of it
is that the filmmakers are
surprisingly willing to do it.
The filmmakers-- Naomi
volunteered her time.
And she, like many of
our other filmmakers,
went to some significant
personal expense
to be able to produce
a Global Lives shoot.
And in many ways this is just
a scaled-up version of someone
who's a really passionate
Wikipedia contributor
and spends months
writing articles.
Right?
It's someone who
believes in the totality
of this global project.
And so they're
willing to really put
a lot of blood, sweat, and
tears, and sometimes money
into that.
And I think that the
onscreen participants, which
is the name we use for the
people whose lives we record,
we say that because
they are really
participating by giving us their
life and access to their life.
I think all of
them that I've met,
and the ones that I've
heard about and talked to,
and heard interviews
with, I think
have an understanding of
what Global Lives is about.
I think it helps that we're
a nonprofit organization,
that we're independent, that
we use the Creative Commons
licenses, that all of
the video that we produce
can be watched for
free on the internet.
And I think they
understand that they're
contributing to something.
STEVE GROVE: Please
join me with questions.
Justin.
AUDIENCE: I imagine it's
pretty wild for them
to have somebody sort of
arrive at their community,
especially with
equipment in their face.
What is that sort
of relationship
like as you arrived
to them [INAUDIBLE],
having to spend a
lot of time together?
NAOMI TURE: Yeah.
No.
That's a really
interesting question,
because within the
course of 24 hours,
there is an intimacy
that develops.
So it's filmmaker
and participants
don't know each other at first.
Right?
And we come in.
There's maybe a little
bit of awkwardness
in having a camera pointed
at you for hours and hours
upon time.
But after a certain
amount of time,
and it might be
three or four hours,
you kind of get lost in the day.
So you stop thinking about the
fact that you are filmmaker,
and you are observing someone.
And they stop thinking about the
fact that they're being filmed.
And it becomes this kind of
natural day that progresses.
It has to.
You cannot act in front
of a film for 24 hours.
And then during
that course of time,
there is subtle
communications that
happen, because
we never use words
between the filmmaker
and the participant,
because we're just filming them.
We are kind of a
fly on the wall.
But at the same time, there's
subtle things that happen.
So for example, Huyen
was cooking lunch.
You know, I was filming.
I had an assistant
right next to me.
And as she began
eating, she actually
filled another bowl with rice
and tuna, with fish sauce,
and she kind of
handed it towards us.
It was one of those moments
where you kind of break
the barrier of filmmaker
and participant.
And it was really beautiful.
By the end of it, we hadn't
spoken much to each other.
But we were hugging.
We felt like we were
part of her family.
Everything.
Almost crying.
And it's just 24 hours that
you spend with this person.
But you become very close in
this very interesting way.
STEVE GROVE: How well do you
think you got to know her?
I mean, how well do
you think you can say,
I feel like I know who this
person is after 24 hours?
NAOMI TURE: I mean, do
we know anyone that well?
I think what it is is
you get to know someone
well enough that the kind
of ideological boundaries
or the cultural differences
kind of start bleeding away.
And it's like, OK.
It's enough to make that
personal connection,
that personal leap of stepping
out of your own reality
into someone else's reality.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: And that's
actually part of the goal
is when you come to a
Global Lives exhibit
or you come to our
website, that you
have an experience of seeing a
lot, and hopefully seeing a lot
that that's not familiar to you.
But also you leave
the exhibit, or you
leave the website knowing that
you haven't seen everything,
and that you couldn't
possibly see all of it.
And in many ways that's the
type of attitude about the world
that we hope to bring,
which is a curiosity,
a desire to learn more.
But a certain
humility and knowledge
that there's a whole lot
more that you really don't
know and can't know.
But it's still worth trying.
STEVE GROVE: How many
folks in the room
would agree to have your
life filmed for 24 hours?
Roughly half.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: We're
going to take your names
on the sign up sheet.
STEVE GROVE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: First of all,
this is a incredible way
to extend empathy.
Really impressed
with the project.
This is the first time
I'm hearing about it.
VR is increasingly being
spoken of as a tool
from a storytelling
perspective to extend empathy.
And I think a really great
example, a recent great example
of that is "The New York
Times" documentary "Displaced."
Is that something that you guys
have thought about going into?
And if so, what would
that look like in terms
of the video installation?
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: So we set a
standard about seven years ago
that we only do shoots in
high definition, 1080p film.
And we might have set that a
little bit early in the sense
that it was kind of a challenge
in places like rural Indonesia
to find at that point
seven years ago,
eight years ago, a camera that
could shoot at that level.
And so today, setting a standard
and using our current structure
of being a really
volunteer-driven network
of filmmakers around the world,
doing a series shot all in VR
would be, I think, not
possible with this community.
However, if there
were a very generous,
well-resourced
company that wanted
to give us a lot of
cameras and probably
a lot of technical support
and stitching software,
and then probably Cloud-based
stitching to put together
all of this, and if there were
a platform capable of stitching
together a 16 GoPro
array-based 24-hour long shoot,
I think it would crash systems.
I don't think it's
doable right now.
But I'm ready to try.
And I have talked to a few
people at companies like that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] You
talk about the empathy piece.
And that's really
fascinating to me.
And I think from our
culture, we often
tend to have this sort
of savior complex,
like, how can I help you.
And I'm curious to know
what out of this project
do we have to learn from
them and other cultures?
And can you talk to
that piece around sort
of the insights that
come out, and sort
of like you're discovering
sort of the most
beautiful pieces of culture.
And how can we share that and
take that around the world?
NAOMI TURE: Yeah.
I think just even
from the filming
that I did in
Vietnam-- so one thing
that we really try
to do-- and I'm
unique in that I went
to Vietnam to film.
But I filmed with a local crew.
So what Global
Lives attempts to do
is get a crew situated
already in that country
to film a participant
within the country.
So I think that's
important in that you
have to kind of understand your
own kind of cultural context.
But then the other
thing is that you
begin questioning your own
assumptions, your own ideology,
your own culture.
So we had been stressed
out on cell phones
like every second of the day.
We arrive on the boat.
And Huyen and her
brother and the worker,
they didn't say
anything for an hour.
They're just sitting
helming the boat.
And that's it.
And so just that
perspective of oh,
they're not online all the time.
You know, here's a different
perspective of life.
Or her definition
of success isn't
to reach the top of the ladder.
Her definition of success
is to help her family,
is to be happy, you know?
So I think the
definition of life
itself is going to be different.
And that's what
you begin to learn.
And you begin to learn
that you know what?
My world view may
not be important
when it's put into the
context of someone else's,
or the multiple narratives.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS:
Yeah, absolutely.
So one of the communities
that I didn't mention that
much so far that's
involved with Global Lives
is the translators.
We've had about 1,500
volunteer translators
from all over the world that
have contributed their time
to subtitling all of this
500 hours or so of footage
that we produced.
And one of the
translators from Malawi
was actually living in the UK.
And she sent us a story.
She said that she was raising
a daughter who I think
was around seven years old.
And she would show her daughter
video from the Global Lives
shoots that she was subtitling.
The shoot was from
Malawi where she grew up.
And her daughter, I don't
think, had been to Malawi.
And using the videos as a tool
to show her daughter what life
would have been like back home
if she had grown up there,
which I found was
really touching.
And she also said that for
her, the Global Lives videos
are a way that the
community that she's part of
can speak to and share
their voice with the world.
And to me that was
really touching.
Now on the education side,
our whole curriculum, again,
designed at the Stanford
Graduate School of Education.
Steve has a copy right
there behind him.
And there are some here to grab.
It's called Unheard Stories.
And it's all about
building empathy
through the Global
Lives project.
And this was designed by
a group of grad students,
that they came up with that
idea to focus on empathy.
They built it around the Common
Core curriculum standards.
And then they came up with
some metrics, which we then
use surveys to
study, to think about
does Global Lives make
students more interested
in learning another language?
Does it make students
more interested
in helping someone who
they see who's in trouble?
Does it make students
feel more like they can
make a difference in the world?
And so all of those, in
a number of questions,
we're seeing
significant increases
in before and after
watching the videos.
Now from my perspective,
Global Lives
is a little more about art
and about asking questions
than increasing
numbers of people
that have certain emotions.
But at the same time, in the
education field which we've now
dipped our toes, and
increasingly a whole leg
into-- as I fall off the
chair-- those kinds of numbers
and that kind of research
is really important.
STEVE GROVE: Other questions.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
Just a question
about the time issue.
What ideas, or what kind
of vehicles have you used
to compress that time
[INAUDIBLE] in the life of this
person and not have to
sit through 24 hours to--
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: So the
shoot that you saw from Vietnam
that Naomi produced, that was
a three-minute summary video
of the 24 hours in Vietnam.
So all of the crews
produce a short
that's based on the 24 hours
that we use in situations where
we can't invite someone
into an exhibit.
NAOMI TURE: But I
think even talking
about that 24-hour
format, I mean,
that's what's really special
and unique about Global Lives.
And so it's kind of the
purest form of documentary.
It's unedited.
And so in an installation
format, when you're
stepping inside and seeing the
unraveling of a daily life,
you might come upon a very
mundane moment, you know.
Someone is just
hiking up a mountain.
Someone else is
brushing their teeth.
And so that forces you to
rethink what narrative is,
and to rethink the fact that
we put a lot of narratives
on everything we
see in the media.
Right?
There's always some
sort of opinion.
And so this is as pure as
possible in terms of cinema
verite, just unraveling.
And that allows us to ask those
questions and begin dialogue.
STEVE GROVE: So David,
I'm guessing no one other
than you has seen more of
these films in their entirety
and had time to think
through what they mean.
I'm curious what you
learned about people
throughout this project.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: Yeah.
So one of the reasons
is-- I've been working
on Global Lives for 11 years.
And that is a really long time,
especially in our generation.
And the real reason that I keep
with it is watching the footage
is still challenging to me.
When I come to the
exhibit, I still
almost always see something
new that I haven't seen before,
or I notice something new
in the piece of the video
that I haven't seen before.
And it's always challenging.
It's always challenging to think
how-- I didn't mention this.
But so Naomi and I met
here in Mountain View.
We were both living
here at the time.
I went to Mountain
View High School.
And growing up in
Silicon Valley,
I had a pretty comfortable
existence here.
And I live in San Francisco now.
And I still have a pretty
decent, comfortable life.
And when I watch the
Global Lives footage
from around the world,
there's no convincing story
I've come up with to tell
myself about why I deserve all
of the privilege and the
resources and the comforts
that I have.
And the reason I keep
doing Global Lives
and trying to bring this footage
to more and more audiences
is because that is
still a challenge to me.
And I think increasingly it's
a conversation with the Occupy
movement, with the
Ford Foundation just
announcing that their entire
focus of all their grant-making
is around inequality, with
Barack Obama talking more
and more about
inequality, I think
that's a conversation
increasingly
we're ready to have as a globe.
But I think it's still a
really important challenge.
And I hope that
Global Lives provokes
more of those kinds
of conversations.
STEVE GROVE: Great.
Well, we're almost out of time.
I know that for those
who do have the time
to come over and see
the exhibit live,
we're gonna do a quick
walkover and a walk through it.
It's fantastic to see.
Please join us if you can.
Any final questions
before we wrap?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So the thing
about [INAUDIBLE] like pose
a challenge is
measuring the success
and sharing all of
your documentary,
and just like how you go about--
what metrics you might use.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: Yeah.
So as I mentioned in
our education program,
we've developed a couple
of different surveys.
There's actually a movement
within the psychology community
called positive psychology
that is all about finding ways
to increase the prosocial
behaviors is a term that they
use, between people, and looking
at ways to influence and then
measure if people are becoming
more empathic and more
kind to each other.
And so we actually had a
psychology graduate student
at Berkeley develop a survey
to figure out in real terms
whether the experiences of
watching this footage actually
draws you out of yourself
and makes you someone who's
thinking more about others.
And again, the initial
results are very good.
However, it's really expensive
to do randomized control trials
in a really systematic way.
And it's also a challenge
because a lot of grant-makers
want to see that
information when
they're grant-makers
in certain categories.
And we have initially
good results.
But I'm always looking
for ideas and ways
we can develop that more.
I'm sure there's a way we
could do that with visitors
to our website too.
And I haven't gotten around
to implementing that.
I'd love to hear
more of your ideas
after, if you have them,
about how to do that.
STEVE GROVE: Great.
Well, David, Naomi, thank you
so much for being with us today.
Thank you.
Round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE GROVE: Thank you.
Thank you also for the project.
I think in addition to being
an amazing contribution
to the film-making, and
the arts, and the culture,
and the education communities.
It's also just a great
contribution to humanity.
So thank you for doing
what you're doing.
And please come back again.
And for those who
have time, I think
we're gonna walk over
and actually check out
the exhibit live.
DAVID EVAN HARRIS: Well,
thank you so much to Steve
for hosting us here.
We really, really appreciate it.
And to Naomi for joining.
So big applause for both of you.
[APPLAUSE]
STEVE GROVE: Great.
Thanks, guys.